As time goes on, it's high-tech,
and it's not too cold
. Because we enjoy so much, we look for old things
.
Something about that. I think it's a very important time now to look back on what we threw away in the
past, rather than plastic.  I
think a lot of people are now thinking that I like ceramics or that I like ceramics that give a warm feeling to propelling rather than numbers
.
He rested longer than here and stood in the ring.
But at that time, everything was self-sufficient, so he
did farm equipment and furniture in the village in that neighborhood.
He thought there was some loss, so
he sent him to study abroad in
music
5. I've seen it since
I was young  So, I went to college, so I
relaxed a little bit towards design, and there
are a lot of people who do theoretically earn money.
What I see again is diverse and wide
.  I also like to make things, and
in the process of growing up,
I chose art to decide whether I would use the university well or not, and
there I met soil for the first time.
I have a strong sense of duty to want to spend time again.
[Music]
After a certain diet now, it is completely different from what I did back then, and
I
always think that we need to design a group that suits our age.
[Music] A
lot of my attitude when making dishes is
that  Its use when it is on the table  I always think that
it is now together, perhaps for a table,
and it creates a good atmosphere.
[Music
] Oh yes, the
food culture itself is the center
of everything
When I put this in that bowl, I want the bowl and food to combine
to become a real work of art or to be born with its functionality
.
For
example, as if there are many dragon tools, the pattern is beautiful,
then it is called the aesthetics of slowness, and
since I don't see it too much time, I think there is nothing that neutralizes me a little because of this traditional
thing.
Tradition and modernity  I'm hoping that a run time that harmonizes like this will come.
[Music]
So it's our job to continue and preserve and do it, and
I think those parts are going out of the way
together.  Just like we are trying to make good things, future
generations will see what we are now or be inspired by it
, so that the beauty of the tradition that we continue to
carry on is.  There is
[music]